Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS SEEK
AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESS.
THIS IS HONEYCOMB.
[ GASPS ]
WE CAN'T KEEP THEM
IN STOCK.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
I'M IMPRESSED.
I REALLY, REALLY AM.
Herjavec:
THAT IS SO CUTE!
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY,
AND FIGHT EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
John: KNOW WHAT?
SILENCE.
I'M ABOUT TO MAKE AN OFFER.
Narrator:
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
Millogo:
I'M FROM WEST AFRICA.
I WAS THERE WHEN THE WAR
BROKE OUT IN MY COUNTRY.
I HAD MY FATHER IN MY ARMS,
LITERALLY, WHEN HE DIED.
I'VE INVESTED RETIREMENT,
COLLEGE FUNDS,
MY PARENTS' RETIREMENT.
WOW.
YOU ARE ALL FREAKIN' IN.
THIS IS HOW ANGELS
AND VCs INVEST.
YOU'RE TELLING US
HOW THEY INVEST?
HOW TO INVEST?
BAD MOVE.
I WOULD HAVE TO BE IMMORTAL
TO GET MY MONEY BACK.
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO ANSWER THE ONLY QUESTION
THAT MATTERS IN "SHARK TANK" --
HOW DO I MAKE MONEY?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A UNIQUE WAY
TO BRING A CHILD'S IMAGINATION
TO LIFE.
HI. I'M ALEX FURMANSKY
FROM PALM BEACH, FLORIDA.
I'M RAISING $100,000
IN SEED FUNDING
FOR 5% OF MY HEARTWARMING
COMPANY, CALLED BUDSIES.
CHILDREN HAVE
THE MOST AMAZING MINDS.
THEIR IMAGINATION INSPIRES THEM
TO CREATE THE MOST
FANTASTIC ARTWORK.
SO, RATHER THAN LET THEIR
ARTWORK TAKE OVER OUR FRIDGE
OR GET LOST IN PILES IN ATTICS
OR BASEMENTS, GONE FOREVER,
HOW CAN WE TREASURE IT?
IMAGINE IF WE COULD MAGICALLY
TRANSFORM YOUR CHILD'S ARTWORK
INTO SOMETHING REAL, SOMETHING
TANGIBLE...SOMETHING HUGGABLE.
NOW WE CAN,
WITH MY COMPANY, BUDSIES.
BUDSIES BRINGS KIDS' ARTWORK
TO LIFE.
KIDS LOVE THEIR BUDSIES
MORE THAN ANY OTHER TOY
BECAUSE THEY THEMSELVES
DESIGNED IT.
THEY ARE THE ONLY CHILD
IN THE WORLD WITH THAT BUDSY.
WE'VE MADE EVERYTHING FROM
ORANGE DINOSAURS TO COWGIRLS
TO ONES I CAN'T REALLY
FIGURE OUT A NAME FOR,
BUT THOSE ARE MY FAVORITE.
YOU KNOW, IN THIS WORLD WHERE
KIDS ARE GLUED TO THEIR PHONES
AND THEIR TABLETS,
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT A PRODUCT
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER IMAGINATION
AND REAL-WORLD PLAY.
SO PLEASE, SHARKS, HELP ME
BRING THE MAGIC OF BUDSIES
TO MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
AROUND THE WORLD.
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT, I'D LOVE TO SHOW
YOU SOME OF OUR CREATIONS,
STARTING WITH ROB.
WE HAVE A ROBOT MONSTER DUDE.
OH, VERY COOL.
THANK YOU.
LORI, WE HAVE -- I THINK THIS
WAS A SELF-PORTRAIT OF SOMEONE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
LOOKS SO MUCH
LIKE YOU, LORI.
MR. WONDERFUL, OF COURSE,
THE HEART, JUST FOR YOU.
ONLY LOVE FOR YOU.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THE BIG, BAD WOLF.
AND THE SHARK.
THANK YOU, MARK.
John:
SO, LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
THE CHILD DRAWS THIS,
AND YOU MAKE IT.
Furmansky: EXACTLY.
SO PARENTS SIMPLY TAKE A PICTURE
OF THEIR KID'S ARTWORK,
WITH ANY CELLPHONES.
THEY TEXT THAT IMAGE TO US.
OUR SOFTWARE
AUTOMATICALLY EXTRACTS THE IMAGE
AND BINDS THAT TO THEIR ORDER.
FIRST, WE HAVE A DESIGNER HERE
IN THE STATES.
SHE INTERPRETS AND APPROVES
EACH ARTWORK THAT COMES IN.
AFTER THE DESIGNER HERE
APPROVES IT,
THE ORDER GETS ROUTED
TO A FACTORY OF OURS IN CHINA.
Greiner:
WHAT DOES ONE COST?
THESE COST $69 IN RETAIL.
WHOA.
Furmansky:
IT COSTS US ABOUT $35 TO MAKE,
SO WE HAVE A 50% MARGIN.
ALEX,
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE?
WHAT'S THE LEAD TIME
FOR ONE?
SO, CURRENTLY,
IT TAKES FOUR WEEKS.
OH!
AND THAT SCALE WE GONNA --
THAT DOWN TO TWO WEEKS.
THE KID HAS GROWN UP
AND GONE TO COLLEGE
BY THE TIME THE THING ARRIVES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Furmansky: NOT AT ALL.
IN FACT, YOU'D BE SURPRISED.
THESE KIDS -- WE'VE GOTTEN SO
MANY VIDEOS THAT PARENTS SENT US
OF THE KIDS OPENING,
UNWRAPPING THEIR BUDSIES.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING THIS?
WE'VE BEEN NOW SELLING
FOR SEVEN MONTHS.
SO, IN SEVEN MONTHS,
YOU'VE SOLD HOW MANY?
2,000.
Greiner:
IN 7 MONTHS, 2,000?
CORRECT.
SO, WHAT WAS
YOUR GROSS REVENUE?
$94,000 IN REVENUE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE
ON THAT?
GROSS MARGIN -- WHAT WERE
YOUR GROSS MARGINS?
GROSS MARGINS -- SO, $39,000.
WOW.
YOU'VE BASICALLY TOLD ME
THIS BUSINESS IS WORTH
$2 MILLION TODAY.
SURE.
ALL RIGHT,
$100,000 FOR 5%.
SURE.
YOU MAKE NO MONEY.
YOU'VE ONLY SOLD
2,000 UNITS.
SURE.
HOW DO I MAKE MONEY?
RIGHT, VERY IMPORTANT. SO --
YES, IT IS.
I'VE SEEN US SELL 2,000 OF THESE
IN JUST 7 MONTHS.
I KNOW THIS HOLIDAY SEASON,
WE CAN GET TO 6,000
WITHOUT A PROBLEM.
THAT'S $450,000 OF REVENUE.
AND THE NEXT YEAR,
I KNOW WE CAN SELL 28,000 UNITS,
WHICH IS $2.4 MILLION
OF REVENUE.
SO THAT'S HOW YOU MAKE MONEY.
I THINK THAT THIS IS GONNA BE
REALLY HARD TO SCALE.
I SEE US
AS BECOMING THE BUSINESS --
THE WORLDWIDE LEADER IN
ON-DEMAND CUSTOM PLUSH ANYTHING.
FOR EXAMPLE,
LET'S TALK ABOUT CORPORATE.
CORPORATE, IN TERMS
OF MASCOTS, EMBLEMS, LOGOS.
WE'VE JUST --
THIS EXISTS.
GUYS DO IT ALREADY.
YEAH, THERE'S LOTS OF
COMPANIES THAT DO THAT.
BUT ALL OF THEM HAVE MINIMUMS.
SO INSTEAD OF ME BUYING ONE
FOR EACH OF MY KIDS,
YOU CAN SELL 50 TO A BRAND.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
HOW YOU CAN AUTOMATE THAT.
YOU HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
THAT IS SO COMPLETELY
DIFFERENTIATED
THAT YOU PREEMPT OTHER PEOPLE
FROM COMPETING WITH YOU.
IF YOU'D HAVE WALKED IN
AND TALKED ABOUT 3-D PRINTERS
AND HOW YOU'RE ALL SET UP,
BING, BING, BING, BING, BING.
BUT YOU TALKED ABOUT
NONE OF THAT.
IT'S STILL "CREATE, PICTURE,
SHOW, SO...DONE."
YES. YES.
BUT WE ARE THE GO-TO PEOPLE
TO DO THAT.
YOU'RE NOT. I'M OUT.
THE PROBLEM I'M HAVING WITH IT
IS PLUSH TOYS --
IT'S A MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR
GLOBAL BUSINESS.
THE PRICE POINT'S
EXTREMELY LOW.
I THINK I COULD FIND THIS
FOR $9.99, OKAY?
BUT IT WOULDN'T BE YOUR CHILD'S.
I GOT IT. I GOT IT.
BUT I'M NOT MAKING
ENOUGH MONEY,
BECAUSE I CAN
NEVER SCALE IT.
I MEAN, YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO ANSWER THE ONLY QUESTION
THAT MATTERS ON "SHARK TANK" --
HOW DO I MAKE MONEY?
EVERYTHING ELSE
DOESN'T MATTER.
WHO CARES ABOUT THIS?
YOU NEED TO MAKE MONEY.
SO 65% MARGIN
IS NOT ENOUGH FOR YOU?
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
NO, IT ISN'T ENOUGH.
IT ISN'T ENOUGH AT ALL.
YOU CAN'T --
YOU CAN'T DO ENOUGH UNITS.
Greiner: I THINK THIS IS
A REALLY CREATIVE IDEA.
YES.
BUT THE PRACTICAL ASPECT --
I DON'T SEE THIS AS SOMETHING
THAT WILL EVER BE SCALABLE.
I SEE IT AS A NICE, LITTLE
BUSINESS THAT YOU CAN DO,
BUT I DON'T THINK
IT WILL EVER BECOME BIG,
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA SOLVE
THE VOLUME ISSUE.
THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKE MONEY IN PLUSH
MAKE MILLIONS OF UNITS
AT A VERY LOW COST.
HERE'S THE ONLY WAY IT WORKS,
IN MY VIEW.
AND I HAVE TO -- I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
AND IN SOME WAYS, YOU'RE
INCREDIBLY LUCKY YOU'VE MET ME.
BUT HERE'S HOW THIS WORKS.
THERE IS NO POSSIBLE WAY.
HE ALWAYS THINKS THAT.
SILENCE.
I'M ABOUT TO MAKE AN OFFER.
I DON'T WANT
TO HEAR ANY NOISE.
O'Leary: I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
AND IN SOME WAYS, YOU'RE
INCREDIBLY LUCKY YOU'VE MET ME.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
$100,000 FOR 50%.
YOU WILL NEVER SELL
ANOTHER ONE FOR $69.
THE MINIMUM PRICE
IS $249.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY
YOU'LL EVER MAKE MONEY
OR PAY ME BACK.
Greiner:
THAT'S A GOOD PLAN --
KIND OF LIKE A TOASTER
IN A BATHTUB.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY.
SO, I -- I WANT
TO REITERATE HOW THIS
BECOMES AUTOMATED
CUSTOM-PLUSH ANYTHING.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
KIDS' ARTWORK.
WHAT I'VE FOUND IS THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING IN YOUR FAMILY
THAT PEOPLE LOVE
AS MUCH AS KIDS.
Greiner: DOGS.
O'Leary: MONEY.
PETS.
WAIT, THERE'S MORE.
SO WE'VE ALREADY HAD DOZENS
OF PEOPLE SEND US --
THAT'S A DOG?
WE CREATE A BUDSY VERSION
OF THEIR PETS -- PETSIES.
WE'VE MADE DOGS, CHICKENS...
Herjavec: WHO HAS A CHICKEN
FOR A PET?
I KNOW.
YOU'D BE SURPRISED.
PEOPLE LOVE THEIR PETS.
WHILE YOU'RE AT IT,
WHY DON'T YOU DO DEADSIES?
GRANNY BITES IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
DEADSIES?
DEADSIES, INTERESTING.
I THINK IT GOES BIG.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING PEOPLE
LOVE EVEN MORE THAN THEIR KIDS,
AND EVEN MORE THAN THEIR PETS.
I SWEAR, IT'LL WORK.
PEOPLE LOVE THEMSELVES.
AND SO WE'VE HAD PEOPLE --
YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE
GONNA BE CRYONIC, BUT...
O'Leary: I'M LIKING IT.
I'M STARTING TO LIKE IT.
[ ALL TALKING AT ONCE ]
...PHOTOS OF THEMSELVES
TO BE TURNED INTO BUDSIES.
OH, MY GOD!
I-I BROUGHT A FEW THINGS,
LEST YOU JUDGE TOO HARSHLY.
SO, LORI, YOU WANT A BUDSIE
VERSION OF ME TO SLEEP WITH?
OH, MY GOD!
MARK, YOU WANT --
O'Leary: OH, YEAH.
[Laughing] YOU WANT
THE BUDSIE VERSION OF ME?
Herjavec:
THAT IS SO CUTE!
Cuban: I'LL TRADE YOU.
OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
THANKS. THAT'S AWESOME.
THANK YOU.
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE
UNREALISTIC IS YOUR ASK --
$100,000 FOR 5%
OF THE COMPANY.
AND THAT KIND OF
MAKES ME BELIEVE,
IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE BUSINESS,
YOU'RE CRAZY.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT YOU DESERVE $2 MILLION
VALUATION ON THIS COMPANY?
THIS VALUATION
IS WITH YOU COMING IN
AND US BUILDING THIS BUSINESS.
YEAH, BUT THEN YOU'RE --
SO, WAIT, WAIT,
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
YOU'RE CHARGING ME
TO COME IN,
AND YOU'RE PUTTING A VALUATION
ON THE COMPANY
AS IF I WAS IN.
NO, THIS IS HOW, UH,
HOW ANGELS AND VCs INVEST,
IS YOU INVEST IN THE VALUE --
YOU'RE TELLING US
HOW THEY INVEST?
HOW TO INVEST?
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: MY PROBLEM IS YOU WANT
TO BE IN THE PLUSH BUSINESS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE DOGS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE CHICKENS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE DEAD PEOPLE,
I THINK I HEARD YOU SAY.
[ Laughing ]
THERE'S NO DEAD PEOPLE HERE.
DEADSIES.
DEADSIES I LIKE.
THAT WAS YOUR IDEA.
DEADSIE WORKS.
WHEN YOU'RE THIS SMALL,
YOU'VE GOT TO BE
LASER-LIKE FOCUSED.
ALL I WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU IS
"THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO."
AND WE HAVE BEEN. SO -- SO --
"THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO."
I HAVE BEEN. I HAVE BEEN.
BUT YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE NOT.
I HAVE BEEN.
YOU KEEP TELLING ME YOU'RE
GONNA BE A PLUSH BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE TO BE
LASER-FOCUSED.
I'M EXPLAINING THE VISION
FOR ONE-YEAR, THREE-YEAR,
AND FIVE-YEAR,
BECAUSE I'M NOT BUILDING
JUST THE PRODUCT.
I'M BUILDING A BUSINESS.
YEAH.
ALEX, FOR ME,
I GOT TO KNOW
HOW YOU'RE GONNA GET
THROUGH THE NEXT 12 MONTHS
BEFORE YOU TELL ME
ABOUT THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
WITH JUST --
WHICH IS BUDSIES.
AND YOU HAVEN'T
DONE THAT TODAY.
YOU'VE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
TOO WIDE FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
WHAT PART OF THE NEXT 12 MONTHS
HAVE I NOT --
I NOT HELPED YOU UNDERSTAND?
THE PART WHERE
YOU MAKE MONEY, ALEX.
THE PART
WHERE YOU MAKE MONEY.
WHO'S LEFT? WHO'S LEFT?
WELL, I HAVE AN OFFER
ON THE TABLE.
KEVIN GAVE AN OFFER.
THERE ARE TWO SHARKS LEFT.
John: I HATE TO SAY IT,
THAT OFFER'S ACTUALLY DECENT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU AN OFFER
OF $100,000 FOR 40%.
OKAY, LET ME MODIFY MY OFFER,
BECAUSE
THERE'S COMPETITION NOW,
AND LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT I'LL DO FOR YOU.
I WILL LEAVE MINE AT 50%,
BUT I'LL LET YOU
PRICE THE PRODUCT,
WITH THIS ONE COVENANT
THAT WILL FORCE YOU BACK
TO REALITY.
YOU CAN'T TAKE ANY MONEY
OUT OF THE COMPANY
UNLESS I'M GETTING 50 CENTS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR.
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA MAKE MONEY
AT $69.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO INCREASE
THIS WAY HIGHER.
MAYBE IT'S $199.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE GONNA FIGURE IT OUT.
BUT YOU CANNOT MAKE MONEY
AT 69 BUCKS, EVER.
I COULD TAKE IT UP TO 20%, BUT
WE'D NEED A HIGHER CHECK SIZE.
SO IF YOU WANT MORE SKIN
IN THE GAME,
YOU HAVE TO PUT MORE SKIN
IN THE GAME.
SO --
[ LAUGHS ]
$100,000 FOR 40% --
THERE IS NO COUNTER ON THAT,
BECAUSE YOU ARE CRAZY
AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S MY FINAL OFFER.
I RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO SAY NO.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONE.
AND THEN THERE'S KEVIN.
OKAY, SO,
I STILL WANT 50%.
YOU FOUND A UNIQUE WAY
TO GET SOMEBODY TO PAY YOU
A LOT OF MONEY
FOR AN EXPERIENCE --
JUST NOT ENOUGH.
I'D LIKE
TO SEE YOU CHARGE MORE
SO YOU CAN MAKE MONEY
ON EVERY ORDER.
SO I THINK, AS YOUR PARTNER,
I'LL HELP YOU GET THERE,
BUT I'LL ALSO GET YOU
SOMETHING ELSE --
A LOT MORE CUSTOMERS
AT A LOW COST.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOOD AT.
I HAVE TO SAY NO TO YOU.
OKAY.
YOU'RE DEADSIE TO ME.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK, ALEX.
TAKE CARE. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE,
UH, MINI-MES.
OF COURSE.
ALL RIGHT, SEE YOU GUYS.
THEY WANTED HALF MY COMPANY.
IT WAS A PRETTY EASY DECISION.
I MEAN, I THINK MY COMPANY'S
WORTH SO MUCH MORE,
AS DO OTHERS, AND SO I'M SORRY
THEY WALKED AWAY,
BUT I'M NOT SORRY.
Narrator:
EARLIER THIS SEASON,
13-YEAR-OLD ANDREA CAO
AND HER MOTHER, HONG,
MADE A DEAL WITH
BARBARA CORCORAN AND MARK CUBAN
FOR THEIR HANDHELD
MASSAGE DEVICE, Q-FLEX.
YOU ARE GONNA SELL
LIKE CRAZY.
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
Andrea:
WHEN WE CAME ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD ONLY SOLD
800 Q-FLEXES.
WE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
A WEBSITE.
SO IN PREPARATION
FOR OUR "SHARK TANK" NIGHT,
MARK GOT OUR WEBSITE
UP AND RUNNING,
AND WE CROSSED OUR FINGERS
FOR SALES.
WHEN WE AIRED,
WE RECEIVED 17,000 ORDERS.
WE'VE GONE
FROM $20,000 IN SALES
TO HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES.
BUT NOW WE'RE SO BEHIND
ON PRODUCTION AND SHIPPING.
WE'VE HAD TO HIRE
FOUR PEOPLE
TO HELP WITH CUSTOMER SERVICE
AND PRODUCT ASSEMBLY.
HERE YOU GO, LAO LAO.
EVEN MY GRANDPARENTS
ARE PITCHING IN TO HELP.
HONG, ANDREA!
HI!
Corcoran: I'M HERE TO HELP THEM
THROUGH ALL THESE ORDERS
AND START THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE NEXT STEPS.
$500,000 IN SALES --
BUT YOU CAN'T KEEP DOING IT
IN YOUR GARAGE.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A FULFILLMENT CENTER.
A FULFILLMENT CENTER
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
BUT THEY'RE GONNA DO IT BETTER.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
PROFESSIONAL PACKERS.
THERE'S GONNA BE BETTER
QUALITY CONTROL.
AND, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
IT'S GONNA GIVE THESE
LOVELY WOMEN THE HOUSE BACK.
WHAT A PLEASURE
TO MEET YOU, SIR.
ONE OF THE MOST SATISFYING
THINGS IN LIFE IS TO FEEL LIKE
YOU COULD HELP SOMEONE WHO HAS
THE SAME SPIRIT YOU HAVE.
IN ANDREA, I SEE MYSELF.
Andrea:
THE "SHARK TANK" EXPERIENCE
HAS COMPLETELY
CHANGED MY LIFE.
I'M HELPING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
I LOOK AT THINGS
DIFFERENTLY,
AND I'VE LEARNED
SO MUCH ABOUT BUSINESS.
MY NAME IS MATT REED,
AND I'M FROM PORTLAND, OREGON.
I LIVE HERE WITH MY WIFE, JILL,
AND TOGETHER,
WE HAVE A BUSINESS CENTERED
AROUND THE HONEYBEE.
HONEYBEES ARE IMPORTANT TO US
BECAUSE THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE
POLLINATION OF OUR FOOD SUPPLY.
WITHOUT BEES,
MOST OF THE FOOD THAT YOU AND I
ENJOY WOULD NOT EXIST.
ALBERT EINSTEIN ONCE SAID,
"IF THE BEE DISAPPEARED
FROM THE FACE OF THE EARTH,
MAN WOULD ONLY HAVE FOUR YEARS
LEFT TO LIVE."
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IT LOOKS
LIKE THAT TIME COULD BE NEAR.
IN 2006,
BEEKEEPERS BEGAN TO NOTICE
HUGE LOSSES
OF THE HONEYBEE POPULATION.
WE'RE NOT SURE WHY
HONEYBEES ARE DYING,
BUT WE THINK IT'S A COMBINATION
OF PESTICIDES, HABITAT LOSS,
STRESS, AND OTHER FACTORS.
IT'S CALLED
COLONY COLLAPSE DISORDER.
I WANTED TO DO MY PART
TO HELP SAVE THE BEES,
AND THAT'S WHEN MY BUSINESS
WAS BORN.
AT THE TIME, I HAD A STABLE JOB
IN THE TECHNOLOGY FIELD.
IT WAS TOO HARD
TO BALANCE BOTH OF THEM,
SO I QUIT MY JOB IN TECHNOLOGY
TO FOCUS ON MY BUSINESS
FULL-TIME.
NOW WE'RE EXPECTING
OUR FIRST CHILD,
AND WE'RE BARELY
MAKING ENDS MEET,
BUT I KNOW THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
MEANT TO DO.
WIT THE SHARKS' HELP, I THINK
WE CAN TURN THIS BUSINESS
INTO SOMETHING THAT IS GOING
TO CHANGE THE WORLD.
HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MATT REED,
AND MY BUSINESS IS BEE THINKING.
I'M SEEKING $400,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF MY BUSINESS.
SIX YEARS AGO, A HONEYBEE
FLEW INTO MY KITCHEN.
MY WIFE NOTICED AND ASKED ME
TO RESCUE THE BEE,
SO I FED IT SOME HONEY.
IT DRANK AND GAINED ENERGY.
I TOOK IT TO THE FRONT PORCH,
AND I WATCHED TRIUMPHANTLY
AS IT FLEW OFF.
WELL, LATER, AS MY WIFE
WAS LEAVING FOR WORK,
SHE NOTICED DOZENS OF BEES
PELTING THE SCREEN DOOR,
TRYING TO GET IN.
THE BEE I'D RESCUED
HAD TOLD HER FRIENDS
ABOUT THE HONEY AT OUR HOUSE.
IT'S AT THAT MOMENT
THAT I WAS STUNG
BY A FASCINATION FOR HONEYBEES.
SO I WENT INTO MY GARAGE
AND BEGAN BUILDING BEEHIVES
OF VARIOUS DESIGNS,
ALL FROM WESTERN RED CEDAR,
AND I STARTED BLOGGING
ABOUT THE PROCESS.
IMMEDIATELY, PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
WERE ASKING TO BUY MY HIVES,
BECAUSE I WAS MAKING
ALTERNATIVE DESIGNS
FROM
THE HIGHEST-QUALITY MATERIALS.
I KNEW I WAS ONTO SOMETHING.
SOON, I COULDN'T BUILD HIVES
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
TODAY, MY COMPANY SHIPS
THOUSANDS OF HIVES
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY
TO CREATE SOME BUZZ
WITH BEE THINKING?
WELL,
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
TO DATE, SINCE WE STARTED
SELLING IN MID-2009,
IS ABOUT $1.9 MILLION.
Herjavec: YOWZA.
WOW.
WHAT ABOUT
THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
THE LAST 12 MONTHS --
SO, THIS YEAR, 2014,
WE'VE DONE $775,000.
AND LAST YEAR?
LAST YEAR WAS ABOUT $560,000.
WOW.
ARE YOU MAKING ANY MONEY OFF
YOUR $750,000, OR $775,000?
SO, SO FAR, PROFIT THIS YEAR
IS AROUND $120,000.
WHO ARE YOUR CUSTOMERS?
IS IT SOMEONE BUYING
FOR THEIR KIDS,
AND IT'S JUST FUN
IN THE BACKYARD?
RIGHT. THE REASON PEOPLE
GET INTO THIS, MOST OF THEM,
SEEMS TO BE BECAUSE THEY --
THEY WANT TO HELP SOMEHOW.
MANY OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW
HONEYBEES ARE DYING,
AND ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR FOOD
SUPPLY RELIES ON THEM.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
YEAH. IT'S TRUE.
SO IT'S -- IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE -- WE KEEP BEES ALIVE.
HOW MUCH IS IT PER BOX?
SO, WELL, THIS HIVE HERE
IS ABOUT $360.
AND HOW MUCH DOES
THAT COST YOU TO MAKE?
UH, THIS HIVE HERE COST US
AROUND $150 TO MAKE.
AND YOU SELL IT FOR $300.
AND THAT'S INCLUDING
SHIPPING AND PACKAGING.
SO, I ACTUALLY HAVE
A LITTLE EXPERIENCE IN BEES.
IN BEEKEEPING,
OF COURSE YOU DO.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
WHEN I WAS YOUNG,
MY GRANDMOTHER HAD
AN APPLE ORCHARD,
AND SHE ARRANGED
TO PUT BEEHIVES
THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE APPLE ORCHARD,
BECAUSE IT PROMOTES
CROSS-POLLINATION
AND CREATES MORE APPLES.
THAT'S WHY YOU DO IT.
THE PROCESS
OF TENDING FOR THEM
INVOLVES EXTRACTING THE HONEY
AND PROFITING FROM IT.
THERE WAS
A SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP.
DO YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE HONEY OUT,
OR COULD YOU JUST LEAVE IT,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE DO --
IT'S MAINTENANCE-FREE?
YOU CAN TAKE TWO THIRDS
OF THE HONEY OUT, CORRECT?
GENERALLY, YOU NEED TO LEAVE
THEM 50 TO 60 POUNDS,
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE.
MY BEES HAVE TO PAY RENT,
SO I TAKE TWO THIRDS.
[ LAUGHS ]
I HAVE NO DOUBT.
THEY PROBABLY LOVE YOU.
YEAH, THEY DO.
THEY'RE VERY HAPPY.
AMAZINGLY, I BELIEVE
THAT HE KNOWS ABOUT BEES.
Cuban: THEY GOT A ROYALTY DEAL
ON THE HONEY.
Herjavec:
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THAT HIVE, THIS HIVE,
AND THE MIDDLE ONE?
SO, I'LL START WITH THIS ONE.
IT'S BASICALLY
OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT.
THIS IS OUR KENYAN TOP-BAR HIVE,
OUR HORIZONTAL TOP-BAR HIVE.
Greiner: WHAT'S IN
THE MIDDLE, THERE?
SO, THIS IS A HONEYCOMB.
SO, THE BEES BUILD ALL THIS
ON THEIR OWN.
[ GASPS ]
SO YOU DUMP IN 10,000 BEES
INTO THIS BOX,
AND THEY'RE GONNA START
BUILDING COMB AFTER COMB.
OH, MY GOD.
THEY'RE WAX-MAKING MACHINES.
DO YOU HAVE TO DO ANYTHING
TO THAT?
I MEAN, DOES HONEY HAVE
TO BE PROCESSED, OR...?
SO, WITH THIS STYLE,
YOU CAN CUT THE COMB RIGHT OFF,
AND THEN YOU COULD CUT IT
INTO SQUARES
AND EAT IT LIKE A SANDWICH.
John: WHERE DO YOU BUY
THE BEES AT?
SO, YOU CAN BUY THEM FROM US,
AT OUR LOCATION.
YOU'RE TELLING ME
IT'S WORTH $400,000 FOR 10%?
$4 MILLION.
THAT'S A $4 MILLION VALUATION
ON YOUR BUSINESS, OKAY?
AND IT REALLY DOESN'T MAKE
ANY MONEY YET.
SO, WE HAVE GROWTH,
AND WE'VE BEEN GROWING RAPIDLY.
WE ALSO HAVE A MARKET
THAT'S GROWING.
NOT REALLY.
BEEKEEPING --
IF YOU ASK ANY BEE SUPPLIER,
IT IS GROWING VERY RAPIDLY.
SO, IS THIS
YOUR FULL-TIME JOB?
YEAH.
I-I USED TO BE IN TECHNOLOGY.
I QUIT THAT JOB,
FINALLY, IN 2012.
MY WIFE QUIT HER JOB
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT.
DO EITHER OF YOU
DRAW A SALARY?
YES, WE DO.
AND WHAT IS THAT?
THIS YEAR,
IT WAS AROUND $50,000,
AND THAT'S 'CAUSE
MY WIFE'S ACTUALLY HOME PREGNANT
RIGHT NOW, NINE MONTHS PREGNANT.
WE'VE GIVEN UP OUR NORMAL
CAREERS AND SECURITY,
HEALTH INSURANCE.
I WENT FROM A CUSH I.T. JOB TO
SELLING BEEHIVES FOR A LIVING.
SO OUR WHOLE LIFE IS AT STAKE.
AND I-I HAVE SEVEN EMPLOYEES,
UH, WHO, YOU KNOW,
THEIR JOBS ARE AT STAKE.
O'Leary: YOU'VE PROVEN
YOU HAVE A BUSINESS.
YOU'VE PROVEN
YOU'VE GOT SALES.
BUT I'M SAYING,
WHEN IS YOUR BUSINESS
GONNA BE WORTH $4 MILLION?
YOU'RE A LONG WAY FROM THERE
RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW,
THE THING ABOUT A BEE --
IT REPRESENTS IMMORTALITY AROUND
THE WORLD IN MANY CULTURES.
I WOULD HAVE TO BE IMMORTAL
TO GET MY MONEY BACK FROM YOU.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, KEVIN.
Herjavec:
THEY'RE BEAUTIFULLY MADE.
HOW MANY DO PEOPLE,
ON AVERAGE, BUY?
SO, AVERAGE ORDER, WHEN YOU
FACTOR IN OUR OTHER EQUIPMENT,
IS AROUND $210.
AND HOW OFTEN DO PEOPLE
REPEAT THE ORDERS?
30% OF OUR ORDERS, IN THE PAST
MONTH, HAVE BEEN REPEATS.
Cuban: YOU KNOW WHAT?
MATT, I'M -- I'M IMPRESSED.
I REALLY, REALLY AM.
I-I THINK YOU DESERVE KUDOS.
I MEAN, PHENOMENAL JOB, TRUE
SPIRIT OF AN ENTREPRENEUR.
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
TAKE WHAT YOU'VE ASKED FOR
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN PROPEL
YOURSELF TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
AND, REALLY,
TAKING IN AN INVESTOR
PROBABLY WILL CREATE MORE STRESS
THAN YOU ALREADY HAVE.
I JUST DON'T SEE IT AS BEING
ABLE TO GROW FAST ENOUGH
TO SHOW ANY RETURN
ON AN INVESTMENT.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANKS, MARK.
I THINK WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS GREAT, AND YOU'RE GREAT,
BUT I AM TRULY
NOT A FAN OF HONEY.
AND SO FOR ME, I CAN'T
GET EXCITED ABOUT THIS,
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I-I REALLY LOVE THAT YOU'VE
GOT IT ALL ON THE LINE.
I MEAN,
YOU QUIT A GOOD JOB,
YOUR WIFE IS PREGNANT,
YOU GOT SEVEN EMPLOYEES.
I MEAN, YOU'RE ALL IN.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO THINK
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
WITH THE $400,000.
MY PROBLEM WITH SALES
IS WE CAN'T MAKE THEM
FAST ENOUGH.
YOU DIDN'T COME OUT HERE AND
SAY, "GEE, IF I HAD MORE MONEY
AND I HAD MORE INVENTORY,
I WOULD SELL MORE."
THE $400,000 ISN'T GONNA
HELP YOU TODAY.
I WISH IT WOULD,
'CAUSE I'D LOVE TO BE
IN BUSINESS WITH YOU.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THERE'S ONLY
ONE SHARK LEFT.
I DIDN'T KNOW
I WAS THE LAST ONE.
I THINK YOU ARE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I WAS FASCINATED BY THIS.
WELL, UH...
...YOU'RE GONNA DO $1 MILLION,
LET'S SAY, THIS YEAR,
AND LET'S SAY
YOU DOUBLE NEXT YEAR.
IF I GAVE YOU $400,000
FOR 10%,
THAT MEANS YOU WOULD MAKE IT
UP TO $4 MILLION,
AND I WOULD GET $40,000,
MAYBE, IN 2 YEARS, 3 YEARS.
IT WOULD TAKE
QUITE SOME TIME
TO SCALE UP
TO GET MY MONEY BACK.
IT JUST DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THE NUMBERS WORK OUT FOR ME.
SO I AM ABSOLUTELY
A CUSTOMER...
ALL RIGHT.
...'CAUSE I LOVE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BUT I AM NOT AN INVESTOR.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATS, MATT.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
THIS BUSINESS IS EVERYTHING
TO MY FAMILY, TO ME.
I'VE GIVEN UP EVERYTHING
TO MAKE IT WORK.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP GROWING,
WITH OR WITHOUT THIS.
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO SUCCEED.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A BETTER
WAY TO SOOTHE AND TEACH BABIES.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS JULIE THOMPSON,
AND I'M FROM ATLANTA, GEORGIA.
I AM SEEKING $100,000
FOR 20% EQUITY.
PARENTS LOVE PACIFIERS
BECAUSE THEY SOOTHE THEIR BABY.
BUT THEY CONSTANTLY FALL
OUT OF THEIR MOUTHS.
I REMEMBER WHEN MY KIDS
WERE BABIES
AND THEIR PACIFIERS
WERE CONTINUALLY POPPING OUT,
AND, OF COURSE, THEY WOULD CRY,
BECAUSE THEY STILL WANTED THEM,
IMMEDIATELY.
OFTEN, IT WAS JUST
BEHIND HIS SHOULDER.
BUT BABIES DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY CAN'T SEE.
THAT IS WHAT INSPIRED ME
TO CREATE THE PullyPalz.
PullyPalz HANG ABOVE THE BABY
AND USE SOMETHING SIMILAR
TO A PULLEY SYSTEM.
WHEN ONE PACIFIER DROPS
AND FALLS OUT OF SIGHT,
ANOTHER IS IN VIEW AND IN REACH.
THIS INTERACTION
ENABLES INDEPENDENCE,
WHICH IS GREAT FOR THOSE TIMES
WHEN PARENTS NEED AN EXTRA HAND.
PullyPalz ARE ALSO
VERY ENTERTAINING
AND PACKED
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL BENEFITS.
PARENTS ARE RAVING
ABOUT MY PRODUCT,
CREATING A DEMAND
THAT I CAN'T KEEP UP WITH.
I COULD REALLY USE SOME HELP.
SO BE A PAL
AND INVEST IN PullyPalz.
THANK YOU, AND I WOULD LIKE
TO PASS OUT SAMPLES.
Greiner:
WE'D LOVE TO SEE THEM.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
OKAY, ROBERT, THAT IS PUDDLES.
OH, THANK YOU, JULIE.
PUDDLES.
THIS IS MoMo.
THANK YOU.
HERE IS ANOTHER PUDDLES.
AND MooMoo.
MooMoo.
APPRECIATE IT.
THERE YOU GO.
Herjavec: JULIE, I REMEMBER
WHEN MY KIDS WERE SMALL --
I'M WITH YOU, HUGE PROBLEM.
PACIFIER FELL OUT
ALL THE TIME.
BUT THEN I BOUGHT A CLIP,
AND THAT SOLVED THE PROBLEM.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THAT AND A CLIP?
THE CLIP HELPED ME KEEP UP
WITH THE PACIFIER,
AND AT LEAST IT DIDN'T FALL
ON THE FLOOR,
BUT IT DOESN'T HELP THE BABY,
'CAUSE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
ONCE IT'S OUT OF THEIR LINE
OF SIGHT.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU HAVE IN SALES?
[ Sighing ] I HAVE --
THE LAST 12 MONTHS, $97,000.
WHICH ISN'T SO BAD
FOR, YOU KNOW...
NO, IT'S NOT SO BAD.
RIGHT.
WHERE ARE THESE SOLD
RIGHT NOW?
THEY'RE SOLD ON AMAZON,
AS WELL AS ABOUT 350 STORES
ACROSS THE U.S.
WHICH STORES?
UM, SPECIALTY, BOUTIQUES.
SO, WHAT DOES THIS COST?
THE RETAIL,
$19.99 UP TO $24.99.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE?
$4.50.
WHERE ARE YOU DERIVING
MOST OF YOUR SALES FROM?
UH, TRADE SHOWS.
YOU MENTIONED
DEVELOPMENTAL BENEFITS.
YES. RIGHT-BRAIN,
LEFT-BRAIN COORDINATION.
HOW DOES IT HELP
WITH THAT?
BETWEEN YOUR RIGHT BRAIN
AND LEFT BRAIN, IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE TWO OF THOSE TO KIND OF
CROSS OVER BETWEEN ONE ANOTHER.
LIKE, THEY -- WHEN THEY'RE
YOUNG, THEY WILL ASK YOU,
"DOES YOUR BABY GRAB SOMETHING
AND PASS IT TO THE OTHER HAND?"
SO BECAUSE
YOU HAVE BOTH SIDES,
THE BABY'S FORCED
TO GRAB AT BOTH.
RIGHT.
SO, THERE IS ONE MORE THING
THAT'S REALLY GREAT ABOUT THIS.
WE RECENTLY DEVELOPED --
YOU CAN SEE ON THAT TREE
RIGHT THERE -- TEETHERS.
THEY POP INTO THE HOLDERS, AS
WELL, SO YOU CAN CHANGE IT UP.
IT GIVES IT MORE VERSATILITY.
YOU CAN PUT A PACIFIER ON ONE
SIDE, TEETHER ON THE OTHER.
PACIFIER ON BOTH.
AS WELL AS,
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT TREE,
THEY'RE CALLED THE MINIZ.
THESE ARE ADORABLE.
THEY'RE LITTLE MINI VERSIONS
OF THE BIG GUYS,
AND THEY ALL COME
WITH A COUNTERPART.
SO, LIKE, THE MONKEY
IS GONNA COME WITH A BANANA
THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY PEEL.
AND IT FITS INTO
THE LITTLE PULLEY SYSTEM?
AND THEY ALL --
EVERYTHING IS DESIGNED TO FIT.
O'Leary:
WHAT IS THE OUTLYING AGE
THAT A CHILD WOULD
STILL USE A PACIFIER?
I SEE 3-YEAR-OLDS WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW, I --
OKAY, LET'S MAKE IT
24 MONTHS, RIGHT?
YES.
TWO YEARS.
THAT'S PROBABLY
THE OUTSTRETCH.
SO, WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION IS 24 MONTHS,
BETWEEN 0 AND 24 MONTHS,
AT ANY ONE TIME?
WELL, OVER 4 MILLION BABIES
ARE BORN IN THE U.S. EVERY YEAR.
OKAY, SO WE SHOULD SAY
THAT 8 MILLION CANDIDATES
ARE WITHIN OUR TARGET,
RIGHT?
SO WE'VE GOT 8 MILLION
CUSTOMERS A YEAR,
AND PRETTY WELL EVERY ONE
OF THEM'S GETTING ONE,
AND YET OUR SHARE,
ON A DOLLAR BASIS,
FROM WHAT YOU TOLD ME,
IS REALLY SMALL.
ARE YOU CONCERNED
WITH THE PRICE POINT
BEING TOO HIGH?
BECAUSE YOU CAN BUY
A PACIFIER
AND AN ATTACHING, YOU KNOW,
ELASTIC CORD THING...
RIGHT.
...FOR,
I DON'T KNOW, 4 BUCKS.
SURE, BUT THOSE DON'T -- YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE NOT INTERACTIVE.
IT'S NOT -- THIS IS NOT
JUST A PACIFIER HOLDER.
JUST -- IT'S COMP--
I'M JUST ASKING,
IS IT DISTRIBUTION
THAT'S THE PROBLEM?
IS IT THE PRICE POINT
WHAT'S HOLDING YOU BACK?
WHAT IS HOLDING YOU BACK?
I'M A ONE-PERSON COMPANY.
I'M EVERYTHING. I'M --
Greiner: SO YOU DO IT ALL?
I DO IT ALL.
YOU DO THE SALES.
I'VE DESIGNED EVERY ONE
OF THESE GUYS,
DOWN TO EVERY PANTONE COLOR
AND EVERY BELLY.
MY SENSE OF WHAT'S HOLDING
THIS WHOLE THING BACK
IS THE PRICE
AND DISTRIBUTION.
NOT MANY PARENTS WOULD
SPEND $20 FOR A PACIFIER.
THAT'S MY OPINION.
THIS ISN'T A PACIFIER.
YES.
JULIE, WHEN YOU PUT THIS
ALL TOGETHER,
HOW MUCH MONEY
DID YOU INVEST?
I'VE INVESTED ABOUT $175,000.
$175,000?
Herjavec: WOW.
WOW. WHERE DID MOST
OF THAT MONEY GO TO?
OH, LET'S SEE. SAFETY TESTING
IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
RIGHT.
ALSO, I HAVE $100,000
IN INVENTORY RIGHT NOW.
OH.
OKAY, SO, THAT'S INTERESTING,
RIGHT THERE, RIGHT?
SOUNDS LIKE YOU INVESTED
A LOT OF MONEY
TO GET THE PRICE BREAKS
DOWN TO $4.50.
YES, I DID.
John: WHERE'D YOU GET
THE $175,000 TO INVEST?
UH, RETIREMENT, COLLEGE FUNDS,
MY PARENTS' RETIREMENT,
CREDIT CARDS.
IT'S -- IT'S SCARY.
YOU'RE ALL IN, HUH?
I AM ALL IN.
WOW.
JULIE, I -- I GUESS
I CAN'T GET MY MIND
OVER THAT CLIP PRODUCT.
OKAY.
AND IT WAS
VERY INEXPENSIVE,
SO I HAVE A BIT
OF A CHALLENGE WITH THAT.
AND IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
FLYING OFF THE SHELVES
AT THIS POINT.
I'M OUT.
I THINK, IN THIS CASE,
INVENTORY ISN'T A GOOD THING.
YES.
YOU'RE JUST NOW
GETTING IT OUT THERE.
AND TO ME, THAT MEANS
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO UPDATE IT
AND GO THROUGH REVISIONS.
BUT YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO COME OUT WITH IT
ON A TIMELY BASIS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SO MUCH
INVENTORY YOU HAVE TO PROTECT.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I -- LIKE I SAID,
I JUST DON'T SEE THE
SELL-THROUGH FAST ENOUGH,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF TWO
SECTORS IN THE TOY BUSINESS --
PLUSH TOYS AND PACIFIER.
PLUSH TOYS --
97% ARE SOLD AT UNDER $10.
PACIFIERS,
AS CHEAP AS A DOLLAR.
SO, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU'VE GOT
THIS INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
DERIVATIVE OF THE TWO OF THEM,
AND I THINK WHAT'S HOLDING YOU
BACK, JULIE, IS THE PRICE.
IF THIS WAS $9.95,
MY BET IS YOU WOULD SELL
FOUR TIMES MORE,
AND YOU CAN'T GET YOUR
MANUFACTURING COSTS
DOWN LOW ENOUGH TO DO IT.
I CAN'T GET EXCITED ABOUT GOING
DOWN THAT ROAD WITH YOU.
I'M OUT.
John: MY CONCERN IS THAT
THE HANGING APPEAL
MAY NOT BE
SELF-EXPLANATORY.
I HAVE DEVELOPED TREES,
SMALLER TREES,
BECAUSE MANY OF MY RETAILERS
WANTED THEM, AND I'VE HAD TO --
O'Leary: THAT'S EXPENSIVE
TO PUT IN RETAIL.
Greiner: DO THEY PUT IT IN?
DO THEY PUT A TREE IN?
THEY DO.
MY -- THE RETAILERS
THAT CARRY THIS PRODUCT LOVE IT
AND ARE EXCITED.
THEY PUT THAT IN
BECAUSE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH, GENERALLY,
SPECIALTY STORES.
BUT IF YOU GO TO A BABIES "R" US
OR BUY BUY BABY,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
THAT ABILITY
WITHOUT THEM CHARGING YOU.
AND I THINK THAT'S --
THAT'S -- THAT'S ONE
OF MY DECIDING FACTORS...
SURE.
...THE FACT THAT I THINK
THAT HANGER APPEAL
IS NOT REALLY THERE,
SELF-EXPLANATORY.
SO...I'M OUT.
SURE.
WELL,
YOU HAVE ONE SHARK LEFT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK
IT'S VERY CLEVER,
SO I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
WHOA!
I DIDN'T SEE THAT COMING.
OKAY.
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU $100,000
FOR 30% EQUITY STAKE.
FOR 30%.
AND I HAVE
THE CONNECTIONS...
YES, YOU DO.
...TO BUY BUY BABY
AND TOYS "R" US.
HMM. LET'S SEE.
WELL, MY ASK WAS $100,000
FOR 20%.
I THINK I JUST HEARD
THIS COW MOO.
[ LAUGHS ]
Greiner: THIS COW MOOED.
Cuban: WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO, JULIE?
YOU'D BETTER TAKE THAT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
SO, I THINK --
WOULD YOU CONSIDER 25%?
OOH.
REALLY?
$97,000 IN SALES
FOR, YOU KNOW, ONE PERSON
AND A HANDFUL OF TRADE SHOWS --
THAT'S -- THAT'S, YOU KNOW...
BAD MOVE.
Herjavec: 5%?
FOR 5%?
YES.
GO 28% AND I'M IN.
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
WE'VE GOT A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
I'M VERY EXCITED.
I THINK IT'S BRILLIANT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I REALLY DO.
I LOVE IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD. WE'LL DO GOOD.
I'M EXCITED
TO WORK WITH YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, JULIE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
I AM SO EXCITED TO HAVE SOMEONE
TO HELP ME AND GUIDE ME
THROUGH THE NEXT STAGES
OF MY COMPANY.
I HAVE BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH
AND INVESTED SO MUCH IN THIS
AND WORKED SO HARD,
SO I -- I JUST CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MUCH IT MEANS
TO HAVE LORI AS A PARTNER NOW.
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY'VE SOLVED
A PROBLEM FOR ATHLETES.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HI. I'M JOEL VINOCUR,
AND THIS IS ARSENE MILLOGO.
WE'RE HERE TODAY SEEKING
$200,000 FOR 15% OF FORUS,
HOME OF THE MOST COMFORTABLE
WALKING, RUNNING,
WORKOUT SHOES
KNOWN TO MANKIND.
WE SET OUT TO DESIGN
THE MOST SHOCK-ABSORBENT
YET LIGHTEST SHOES
ON THE MARKET TODAY,
AND HERE THEY ARE.
FORUS.
JUST BY HOLDING THEM UP,
YOU CAN SEE HOW MUCH LIGHT
AND AIR PASSES THROUGH THEM.
THEY'RE BUILT WITH AN
UNBREAKABLE STABILITY BAR
THAT ALLOWS FOR ANY TYPE
OF WORKOUT,
BUT WEIGHS ONLY A FRACTION
OF WHAT OTHER SHOES WEIGH.
MR. MARK.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A PAIR
FOR EACH OF YOU.
THANK YOU.
Vinocur:
GO AHEAD AND TRY THEM ON.
WHY DO I GET THE PINK COLOR?
[ CHUCKLES ]
IT'S RED.
OH, YES, OF COURSE IT'S RED.
IT'S FERRARI RED.
THEY FEEL PRETTY GOOD.
WHAT MAKES THEM SO SPRINGY?
THERE'S WAY MORE GIVE TO THEM.
THE INSOLE THAT YOU'RE HOLDING
IN YOUR HAND RIGHT NOW --
THE VERY BOTTOM IS GEL.
THE MIDDLE PART
IS MEMORY FOAM.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE INSERT,
WE HAVE
THE DIFFERENT LINES.
THAT'S SET UP TO THE PRESSURE
POINT AS YOU WALK.
SO OVER TIME, THE SHOW
ACTUALLY FITS PERFECTLY.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THE MEMORY FOAM
IS ADJUSTING TO YOUR FOOT?
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
DO YOU HAVE A DESIGN BACKGROUND?
I'M FROM COTE D'IVOIRE,
WEST AFRICA,
AND I WAS THERE WHEN THE WAR
BROKE OUT IN MY COUNTRY.
I LITERALLY HAD TO RUN
TO COME HERE.
THAT WAS AFTER I HAD MY FATHER
IN MY ARMS,
LITERALLY, WHEN HE DIED.
MM.
I CAME TO THE U.S., HERE,
AS A TRACK-AND-FIELD --
ON A TRACK-AND-FIELD
SCHOLARSHIP.
I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL.
WHEN I RAN TRACK,
EVERY SINGLE TIME WE RAN,
THE SHOE THAT WE HAD
HAD A REALLY THIN INSERT.
TWO WEEKS, THE SHOE INSERTS
WERE WORN OUT.
I WENT TO CHINA
WITH MY LAW SCHOOL,
AND I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO MEET ALL THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
WHAT ARE YOU
MAKING THE SHOES FOR,
AND WHAT ARE YOU
SELLING THEM FOR?
IT RANGES FROM ABOUT $11
TO $13 TO MAKE IT.
WE WHOLESALE THEM
FOR ABOUT $35 TO $50,
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTRY,
AND THEN THEY RETAIL
FOR $75 TO $85.
AND WHERE DO YOU SELL THEM?
IT'S A GENERAL RETAIL SALE.
WE HAVE A DISTRIBUTOR IN TAIWAN,
WE HAVE ONE IN HOLLAND,
AND THEN WE HAVE INDEPENDENT
SALES AGENTS ACROSS AFRICA.
AND WHERE IN THE U.S.
ARE YOU SELLING THEM?
CURRENTLY,
WE'RE DOING E-COMMERCE.
WE'RE DOING
A GUERRILLA MARKETING ATTEMPT
SIMILAR TO THAT
OF UNDER ARMOUR,
WHERE WE'RE GIVING THE PRODUCT
TO THE PEOPLE,
AND THEY'RE TELLING PEOPLE
IT'S AMAZING.
LET'S ASSUME
IT'S A GREAT SHOE, OKAY?
IT IS.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
SO WHAT?
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF DIFFERENT
SHOES ON THE MARKET.
THERE ARE SOME PLAYERS
THAT OWN THIS
MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR MARKET.
THEY'VE GOT IT LOCKED DOWN.
WHY WOULD FORUS EVER HAVE
A CHANCE OF GAINING SHARE
AGAINST THEM
TO BE A BIG COMPANY?
EXPLAIN HOW THAT COULD HAPPEN.
HOW ABOUT HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
IN 12 MONTHS?
IT'S ACTUALLY SIX --
SIX MONTHS.
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES
IN SIX MONTHS?
CORRECT.
OKAY, THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
I THINK
YOU'VE CONVINCED EVERYBODY
YOU'VE DESIGNED A DECENT SHOE.
WHAT'S THE PLAN TO INCREASE
SALES BY FOUR TIMES?
YOU'RE ONLY $500,000 RIGHT NOW.
WELL, THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE, ACTUALLY.
NEXT YEAR, WE'VE PROJECTED
ABOUT $2.5 MILLION.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA GET THERE?
THAT'S BASED ON THE CURRENT
ARSENAL WE HAVE.
THE ONLY REASON WE DIDN'T GET
THOSE SALES LAST YEAR
WAS BECAUSE WE MISSED
THE WINDOW OF THE SEASON.
Greiner: YOU KNOW WHAT? TO ME,
THERE'S THESE MAJOR PLAYERS,
LIKE SAUCONY AND NIKE
AND ADIDAS.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU WOULD
ACTUALLY PENETRATE THAT
SO STRONGLY THAT I WOULD GET
BACK MY MONEY.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
I WANT TO SAY ONE THING.
NEXT YEAR, WE ARE SECURING
LICENSING FROM NASCAR --
THE TOP THREE DRIVERS
OF NASCAR.
ARE YOU CREATING A DRIVING SHOE
FOR NASCAR,
OR ARE YOU CREATING
A RUNNING SHOE?
ARE YOU ABOUT FASHION,
OR ARE YOU ABOUT FUNCTIONALITY?
BOTH.
WE'RE CREATING
A LIFESTYLE SHOE
THAT EMBODIES
THE SPIRIT OF NASCAR.
THAT -- YOU'RE CREATING
A LOT OF BATTLES
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE MONEY
TO MARKET TO.
HOW MUCH INVENTORY DO YOU HAVE?
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ABOUT $65,000 -- $68,000.
HOW MANY OF THE RUNNERS' STORES
YOU SOLD TO --
HOW MANY OF THEM REORDER?
ALL OF THEM.
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM.
THEY ALL REORDER?
YES.
WE DON'T HAVE THEM.
WE CAN'T KEEP THEM IN STOCK.
THE CHALLENGE WITH THIS SPACE --
YOU'VE GOT TO GET DISTRIBUTION,
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK
YOU HIT THE BRICK WALL,
BECAUSE TAKING A VERY FAMOUS
BRAND OFF THE WALL
TO PUT THIS THERE, INSTEAD,
THAT AIN'T FREE.
YOUR CHALLENGES
ARE NOT BEHIND YOU.
THEY'RE AHEAD OF YOU.
I'M NOT GONNA GO ON THAT JOURNEY
WITH YOU. I'M OUT.
LOOK, I CAN JUST SEE --
THIS OWNS YOU, RIGHT?
I-IT'S NOT -- IT'S NOT
A BUSINESS. IT'S YOU.
THE REALITY FOR ME IS
THE MAVS HAVE GOT A HUGE DEAL
WITH ADIDAS.
I'VE GOT A BIG DEAL
WITH SKECHERS.
I'M A LOYAL GUY TO THE BRANDS
I'M WORKING WITH,
WHO HAVE BEEN LOYAL TO ME.
I JUST CAN'T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE IT WORK,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
BUT I REALLY WANT YOU GUYS
TO SUCCEED.
THANK YOU.
SO, I'M GONNA TOUCH
ON SOME OF THE THINGS
SOME OF THE OTHER SHARKS SAID.
NOW, YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
DIFFERENT LINES, LIKE NASCAR.
THEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
ABOUT FIVE STYLES IN EACH LINE,
AND EVERY ONE
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE
AN AVERAGE OF SIZE 7
ALL THE WAY TO 13,
AND HALF SIZES, IN EACH COLOR,
THREE SEPARATE TIMES.
THAT CREATES
A LOGISTICAL NIGHTMARE,
BECAUSE YOU TURN AROUND,
AND THEN YOU HAVE $4 MILLION
WORTH OF LEFT SHOES.
I WAS SOMEWHAT INTERESTED.
I WAS ON THE FENCE.
UM...BUT I THINK THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A CHALLENGE.
SO, UH, I'M OUT.
SHARKS, ACTUALLY,
BEFORE WE CONTINUE,
WE -- WE HAVE A, UH, AN
ADDITIONAL THING THAT WE --
AS WE WERE PROMOTING THE SHOES,
WE ACTUALLY DEVELOPED
PROPRIETARY E-MAIL MARKETING
SOFTWARE CALLED ATTLO.
IT TAKES THE E-MAIL MARKETING
FROM THE INSIDE,
AND IT SHOWS IT
IN THE SUBJECT LINE.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY, UH,
HOW WE PLAN TO PROMOTE THESE.
Man: WE'RE OPENING THE DOOR
TO NEW POSSIBILITIES.
NO LONGER ARE WE CONFINED
TO JUST TEXT.
99% OF MARKETING E-MAILS
HAVE IMAGES INSIDE THE E-MAIL.
WITH ATTLO,
USERS CAN INSERT IMAGES
IN THE SUBJECT
AND SENDER FIELD,
GUARANTEEING RECIPIENTS
WILL SEE THEIR CONTENT,
EVEN IF
THE E-MAIL'S NOT OPEN.
THIS IS E-MAIL
AS NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
THIS IS ATTLO.
YOU CAN DO THAT TODAY.
WHO INVESTED IN THAT COMPANY?
ME AND ANOTHER PROGRAMMER.
MAN, YOU ARE FIGHTING
SO MANY BATTLES.
LOOK, A GUY THAT USED TO WORK
FOR ME, HE WAS, AT ONE POINT,
ACTUALLY THE 11th FASTEST MAN
IN THE WORLD.
I RUN FIVE MILES A DAY,
SO I USED TO SAY,
"HEY, LET'S GO RUNNING."
AND HE WOULD SAY TO ME,
"I CAN'T RUN FIVE MILES."
I SAID, "COME ON, MAN,
YOU'RE IN GREAT SHAPE.
YOU CAN RUN FIVE MILES."
"I DON'T RUN FIVE MILES.
I RUN 100 METERS
AS FAST AS I CAN.
THAT'S MY JOB."
I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOUR JOB IS.
YOU'RE DOING A PERFORMANCE SHOE.
THEN YOU'RE DOING
E-MAIL SOFTWARE.
THEN YOU'RE DOING A NASCAR SHOE?
YOU'RE FIGHTING
TOO MANY BATTLES.
IF YOU WANT TO WIN,
JUST RUN THE 100 METERS.
FOCUS.
BUT HERE'S MY CHALLENGE.
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT INVENTORY.
I WANT TO BE INVOLVED.
YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR $200,000 FOR 15%.
I'M WILLING TO PUT UP
SOME OF THE MONEY,
A PERCENTAGE OF THE MONEY.
BUT IF YOU CAN TALK DAYMOND
TO COME BACK IN
AND HE'LL HAVE ME AS A PARTNER,
I'M HAPPY TO COME ALONG,
'CAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE INVENTORY CONTROL
AND KNOWING HOW TO MAKE THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL,
'CAUSE YOU CAN BURN THROUGH
$200,000
[SNAPS FINGERS] LIKE THIS.
SO THAT'S MY OFFER.
I'LL PUT UP SOMETHING, AND
WE CAN FIGURE OUT THE EQUITY,
IF YOU CAN GET DAYMOND
INTO THE RUNNING SHOES.
DAYMOND,
IS THERE ANYTHING THEY CAN SAY
TO CHANGE YOUR MIND --
YES OR NO?
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
ROBERT IS INTERESTED
IN JOEL AND ARSENE'S
ATHLETIC-SHOE COMPANY, FORUS,
BUT ONLY IF DAYMOND
WILL JOIN HIM IN THE DEAL.
Herjavec: IF YOU CAN TALK
DAYMOND TO COME BACK IN
AND HE'LL HAVE ME AS A PARTNER,
I'M HAPPY TO COME ALONG,
'CAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE INVENTORY CONTROL
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL,
'CAUSE YOU CAN BURN THROUGH
$200,000
[SNAPS FINGERS] LIKE THIS.
DAYMOND,
IS THERE ANYTHING THEY CAN SAY
TO CHANGE YOUR MIND --
YES OR NO?
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
IS THERE ANY EQUITY THEY CAN
GIVE YOU TO CHANGE YOUR MIND?
THE WHOLE DEAL'S CONTINGENT
ON YOU COMING BACK IN.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU
WILLING TO GIVE?
THE DEAL IS ONLY AS GOOD
AS THE PERSON
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE,
AND THIS INDIVIDUAL IS A
GO-GETTER WHO WON'T BE STOPPED,
BUT HE ALSO HAS A VISION,
AND I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE
WITH THE VISION.
IF HE GAVE YOU 200K,
WOULD YOU DO IT?
I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE.
I CAME HERE.
I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL.
I HAD TO MOVE TO GO
TO LAW SCHOOL.
OFFER HIM SOMETHING.
DON'T TELL YOUR STORY ANYMORE.
YES.
OFFER HIM SOMETHING TANGIBLE.
I DON'T HAVE ANYBODY IN
MY FAMILY THAT DID BUSINESS.
I LEARNED. YOU KNOW HOW
I GOT TO THIS POINT?
BY LISTENING TO PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE
AN EXCELLENT PRODUCT.
I WILL LISTEN TO YOU,
BECAUSE --
YOU HAVE -- LISTEN TO ME.
YOU HAVE AN EXCELLENT PRODUCT.
I DON'T WANT TO BE EXCELLENT.
I WANT TO BE AMAZING.
AND YOU CAN GET ME TO AMAZING.
YES, I GOT IT.
AND YOU'RE NOT
LISTENING TO ME NOW.
SO, DAYMOND, ARE YOU OUT?
I'M STILL OUT.
LOOK, YOU GUYS ARE ALL IN.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT YOU.
YOU ARE ALL FREAKIN' IN.
MY ONLY HESITATION IS
THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW AREAS
WHERE INVENTORY CONTROL
IS SO CRITICAL.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHERE TO SPEND THAT MONEY.
I CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT SOMEBODY
LIKE DAYMOND.
DAYMOND, WE ARE WILLING TO BE
ABLE TO FIND A COMPROMISE
BETWEEN YOU
AND ROBERT, HERE,
SO WE CAN REALLY LAUNCH
THIS COMPANY.
DO YOU KNOW --
WE WAITED AND PRAYED
TO GET A PATENT ISSUED.
WE GOT A PATENT ISSUED.
I'M OUT.
IF DAYMOND'S NOT IN,
I GOT TO BE OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
Vinocur: YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY,
IT'S DISAPPOINTING
TO NOT GET A DEAL
WITH THE SHARKS,
BUT WE CAN WALK
OUT OF HERE
KNOWING WHAT WE CAN DO
IN THE FUTURE
AND KNOWING
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE GREAT.